these days just about every person
in your business ask questions about
your data
and the faster they can get answers to
those questions the more efficiently
they can do their jobs
not only can optimizing sql queries keep
all your data consumers happy
but it can also save you money in this
video
we're going to talk through some
strategies for optimizing your bigquery
queries
in our last episode we covered query
execution
including several tools and concepts
that provide the foundation
for many of the optimization techniques
we're highlighting today
if you haven't already i highly
recommend taking a pause to watch it
before diving into this one
alright on to the strategies
one of the most straightforward ways to
optimize a query is to make sure that
you limit the number of bytes it needs
to scan
the first thing you want to do is ensure
you are only selecting the columns that
you really need
that means no select star since bigquery
uses columnar storage
the data scan is proportional to the
number of columns used in the query
if you want to take a peek at the first
few rows of the data to get a feel for
what you're working with
use the preview table feature instead
the next thing you can do is leverage
partitioning and clustering to
automatically prune out data you don't
need in your query
like we talked about in our video on
bigquery storage
this includes leveraging filters or
where clauses
on columns used to partition or cluster
the table itself
all right so we went over some
strategies for minimizing the data
scanned in the query
the next thing we can look closer at is
aggregations
to understand how to optimize
aggregation queries
let's look at how bigquery actually
executes a query that uses
a group by clause first the data is read
from our storage system and group buys
are done
on individual slots then the results
from each slot are bucketed using a hash
function
such that data from the same key ends up
on the same slot
we often refer to this as shuffling
so in this query all partial
aggregations for the same wiki title
end up in the same slot and we can see
the shuffle step happening
in the second stage of the execution
details
further aggregation occurs and the final
result is then passed along to the last
slot
for which limits the results since this
requires a few different aggregation
steps
group by queries can be costly for this
reason you want to ensure that you
aggregate as
late and as seldom as possible this can
come into play for queries that have sub
selects
you'll want to move your aggregation
functions up to the top to avoid
multiple group by executions but there
is an exception
if a table can be reduced drastically by
aggregating
in preparation for being joined then
aggregate it early
another thing you can do to avoid using
group buys is to nest repeated data
for example you might have a
transactions table that has
information about the order including
the items that were purchased
if you use flat denormalization you
would have one row for each ordered item
instead you can create a repeated column
that contains a list of all the items
now if you want to calculate the number
of items in each order
you can use array length and avoid doing
any group buys
great so now you have some tactics for
aggregations
but what about joins let's begin by
looking at how bigquery
executes different types of joins if you
join
two large tables together bigquery
favors what's called a hash join
or a shuffle join similar to the
aggregation we discussed before
bigquery uses a hash function to shuffle
both the left
and the right tables so that the
matching keys end up on the same worker
and then the data can be joined locally
on the other hand if one of your tables
is small enough to fit in memory
it's not necessary to shuffle large
amounts of data
in a small join or a broadcast join
bigquery simply sends the small table to
every single node that's processing the
larger table
now that you have a feel for how
bigquery executes joins
let's consider how you can make queries
that join multiple tables
as efficient as possible first off
you want to make sure you place the
largest table first in the join query
followed by the smallest and then by
decreasing size
next where clauses should be executed as
soon as possible
so that the slots for forming the join
are working with the least amount of
data
you also want to make sure we're using
filters on both
tables like in this example here
this way you're ensuring data you don't
need is being eliminated from both sides
of the join
finally you can cluster or partition
tables based on common join keys
because less data is scanned and the
query will execute faster
and actually clustering improves the
efficiency even more than partitioning
so keep this in mind when deciding on
how to structure your tables
one last way to optimize queries is by
tweaking the way you do filtering and
ordering
something you may not realize is that
when you are using a where clause
bigquery assumes that you have chosen
the best order for your filters
meaning the first part of your where
clause should always contain the filter
that will eliminate the most data
next if you're using an order by
statement you may run into a resources
exceeded error
this is because the final sorting for
your query must be done on a single slot
and if you're attempting to order a very
large result set
the final sorting can overwhelm the slot
that's processing the data
one way you can solve this is by making
sure you use limit
so that the result set is easier to
manage
phew okay we were able to cover a lot of
great techniques
to make your queries more performant
more detail on what we discussed here
plus even more optimization levers are
covered in the links below
so be sure to check them out thanks for
joining us today
and watch out for our next episode of
bigquery spotlight
oh and remember stay curious
[Music]
you